grab your hotdogs and say hi to your
mother for me say hi to your mother for
me because we have Mark Wahlberg's
latest action film that doesn't involve
Michael Bay in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into Netflix as
Spencer confidential breaking down its
ending and solving the case along the
way
buckle in it's time to think Story
thanks for driving me to the library for
story time Brian the movie really gets
under way with the deaths of two Boston
police officers Captain John Boylan and
Officer Terrence Graham in fact Terrance
is framed for the murder of John and the
case is swept under the rug when it's
found out that Terrance supposedly
committed suicide
John was a dirty cop that our
protagonist Spencer beat up five years
ago for not looking into the murder of a
local woman named Gloria was new ski you
see Spencer used to shovel snow for
Gloria's mother
okay and when Gloria became an outspoken
activist against developers moving into
Southie she was harassed and later
murdered by Charles vent would a man
hired by Boylan to keep her quiet hence
why the case was covered up fast-forward
five years later and Boylan is found
murdered the same day Spencer is
released from jail most people would
shrug it off and move on with their
lives but not Spencer even though he'd
much rather moved to Arizona and drive
trucks for the rest of his life Spencer
used to work with Terrence and knows him
to be a good man he'd never be a dirty
cop while talking with Terrance's wife
we get a little more insight into
Spencer's motivation to solve this case
he sees a lot of the same qualities and
heard that he saw in his own mother you
know my mom wasn't of a good hand either
but she was fierce tough hard by taking
on this case he's not only taking on a
corrupt system that put him in jail for
doing what is right but also bringing
justice to a world he says is unjust
because zero justice Spencer teams up
with his new roommate Hawk who he
initially doesn't get along with his dog
pearl like some better he has to share
his room with them and he only stalks
the fridge with oatmeal milk Hawk isn't
keen on helping Spencer until he sees
how this case has affected Terrance's
son who will now grow up without a
father
Hawks father was also murdered doing the
right thing and trying to make his
community a better place that's
this scene between hawk and Terrance's
son is so impactful to him he sees
himself as that little boy
Spencer seeks out the security footage
the night Terrance was taken and what is
likely the most non discreet manner
possible
there he finds Terrance got into a
yellow Corvette which he'll later find
belongs to Charles bentwood a member of
the Irish mob with ties to the Dominican
gang known as the trinitarios time
Charles's connection to a new casino
called Wonderland with the help of post
Malone of course Spencer and Hawk find
out a group of cops gang members and
politicians are working together as a
group called los heroes to claim stake
in this new casino even when Spencer has
wiretap proof that Boylan was ratting on
los suspiros to make a deal with the
feds
the FBI agents still say it's not enough
so they do the only logical thing and
throw a hammer into the van containing
all the drugs gaining control of it in
an attempt to lure out the
organization's leader Spencer's former
partner Driscoll but Driscoll fires back
by kidnapping Henry offering his life in
exchange for the millions of dollars
worth of drugs in an ironic shift
Driscoll and his men are ran by Spencer
driving Black Betty just like how they
ran Boylan earlier on in the film it's
also fun to note riding Betty was set up
an hour earlier I get a shot at driving
by hey you're not ready mr. Spencer you
may also have seen the hawk flying
briefly toward them symbolizing the
character of the same name Spencer takes
on Driscoll in a one-on-one making a
citizen's arrest and saying
Mr Justice a change from his character
who once said there is no justice the
FBI swoops in and makes the arrests even
though they basically did nothing the
cops are busted the casino is shut down
and justice is brought to Gloria and
Terrance's murders Hawkins Spencer in
the hospital together sharing beds apart
just like in their home and notice
Spencer's dog has chosen to be with
Spencer but the film ends with the door
wide open for a sequel while enjoying
some celebratory lobster the gang sees
on the news the arrest of a firefighter
responsible for the deaths of over two
dozen firemen in a blaze that burned
down st. Aidan's Church Spencer says he
knows the man who claims that he was set
up and with a final look at Spencer's
face we just know this will be a case
he'll have to look into thanks everyone
for watching this quick video please
make sure to LIKE and subscribe I have
lots more on
way you can also follow me on twitter at
think story whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much